[Music]
on april 20th
oil markets did something they never had
before and
they crashed went into negative
territory
and closed the day at minus forty
dollars meanwhile
uh in a place uh called thaden voice in
essex
a group of nine traders led by a guy
called cuddles
made 660 million dollars over the course
of a couple of hours
the price of oil has collapsed to a
record low we've never really seen
anything like it wti this morning down
more than 35
people maybe wouldn't have been so
surprised if the oil price had fallen to
zero
but the oil price went to -38 it went
far lower than anyone had expected
and so lots of people in the market were
saying well hang on something else is
going on here
a couple of months later i started to
get wind through a kind of network of
sources
that a tiny firm in the outskirts of
london
had made a huge amount of money that day
and potentially had some part to play
and what happened
the information we got was that nine
traders at vega capital london had made
in the region of 660 million dollars
in one day as a group i think they made
as much money in one day as apple makes
from its international sales
in one day i mean it's an insane sum of
money did they pull off a fantastic
trade did they predict the way the
market was moving and get it absolutely
right
or was there something else going on and
had they actually
done something the breached market rules
in a bid to push the market and that
investigation is ongoing
[Music]
so paul commons is a trader who cut his
teeth in
in the pits in the 80s and 90s when
everyone had a nickname
his was cuddles
if you can imagine that was a very sort
of cut throat type of world where people
are doing
you know hundreds of thousands and
millions of dollars trades by
shouting at each other giving hand
signals and then
scrolling on scraps of paper the culture
of
the trading pits in london was very
influenced by
the working class guys who became
traders there they weren't like
the city bankers that had gone before
them they weren't usually oxford or
cambridge
you know they didn't wear savile row
suits they were ordinary working guys
who happen to have
a talent for trading and a lot of them
came from essex
i think it was 400 traders in the pits
and cuddles in his
you know oil and gas pit was described
to us as amongst the top three
among you know in amongst that was very
successful and made
you know very large amounts of money as
a young man but you know inevitably
uh mechanization and the arrival of
electronic markets
um was the kind of death knell for the
pits and in 2005 the ipe
closed down and when the pits shut down
a lot of the traders who worked there
lost their jobs or quit or went to work
for financial institutions
but paul commons decided to start his
own trading collective
out in essex
some of them are ex-pit guys cut from
the same cloth as him
lots of them are actually sort of in
their twenties and they're
he's you know drinking buddy's son or
they're his
own kids friends from football you know
they're young lads
hungry and ambitious and he brings them
into the fold and fairly shortly he's
got
um you know maybe a dozen or so traders
they're independent let's be clear but
they're all part of this collective
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i'll let liam do with essex i am
from essex so i feel like i'm free to uh
you know to get into this sweet as they
say
if you were to ask someone in britain
how they would imagine a kind of essex
person
they would see someone who's maybe some
slightly flamboyant
with a sort of cockney accent a guy
richie style accent
you know not afraid to splash the cash
but it's probably pretty bright and has
done well for themselves
don't even make sense does it but you
know these guys they drove around
very nice rolls royces and bentleys they
went to
places like marbella on holiday
fade and boyce is a very wealthy place
you have to
have considerable income to be able to
afford to live in that village it's a
really nice place to live
and it's 20 minutes to tube ride away
from the city
earlier in the summer we have this lead
which is that there's this tiny firm
called vega capital london
and they were the biggest winners from
the
biggest oil crash in history you know
anyone that covers markets
is going to be surprised about that you
know you're thinking you're bps of the
world or you're glencores but it's this
tiny firm
and one of the big challenges that we
had was actually finding out who worked
with vega capital it wasn't immediately
obvious and at first we had absolutely
no idea
if you go to the vega capital website it
says it's under construction
if you do basic online searching it's
very difficult to find anyone who's
publicly connected to the company
so inevitably we're incredibly curious
at this point like who the hell are
these people
the more reporting we did the more it
became clear that this group were
connected socially as well as
professionally
they went to weddings together they
played golf together they would go on
holiday together
we found out that a number of them were
members of the west ham
supporters club in london a few of them
started companies together so you could
see
all the connections between them and
start to see a distinct group emerging
and it really just was it was this kind
of shock that you know this wasn't just
like a hedge fund or a firm you'd never
heard of this was actually a group of
buddies
who all had the same experience on this
day and had all made a huge amount of
money
[Music]
so if you're an oil trader there's a
number of different ways you can trade
and
probably the most popular is wti futures
contracts
and it's basically a contract that says
i'm gonna buy
a thousand barrels of oil from you at
this point in the future or i'm going to
sell a thousand barrels of oil to you
at this point in the future it's
actually just a financial contract
to gamble on to predict whether oil is
going to go up or down
on the 20th of april in essex there have
been signals for a while that this was
going to be an exceptional day in oil
markets
and we know that some of them arose
early and started their trading in the
early hours of the morning
while it was still dark outside
essentially what they were doing
is buying contracts that gave them an
obligation
to buy oil at whatever the price ended
up at 2 30 pm
so they're basically placing a bet that
oil is going to fall
throughout the day but they're
simultaneously selling lots of oil as
well
and whether they make a profit and how
much profit they make is the difference
between what they buy the oil for
and what they sell the oil for now of
course we now know
throughout april 20th the price dropped
and dropped so
this is going very well for them you
know they are committed to selling oil
at these prices and the prices are
continuing to fall which means they're
going to be able to offset it
and buy oil at cheaper at the end of the
day
now once it gets to kind of 1 30 2 pm
that's when things start to get really
interesting
suddenly there's a kind of influx of of
buyers and sellers
you know as desperation increases in the
market and trading volumes go up
now 208 pm exactly something
bizarre and unprecedented happened which
is the oil
passes into negative territory and it
fell to a record level of minus 38
we've never seen anything like it period
in terms of the contraction
of the global economy that huge gulf
between what they were buying the oil
for what they were selling it for
enabled them to make more money than
they ever thought possible so their
profit was the difference between
-37 and all of these positive numbers on
every contract they sold the price of
crude briefly hit minus 37
a barrel for one group of traders
operating from a small office it was a
very
very profitable day it's important to
remember this this had never happened
before in the history of oil trading
no one could have predicted it i can't
think of another example
of where you enter a trade and you get
paid on both sides you get paid both to
sell
and to buy it you know it's unthinkable
one thing we know about the cuddles
trading arcade is that
they were very comfortable taking large
risks and
you know you have to be clear this was a
large risk yeah we spoke to
oil traders both people that know these
guys and people that don't
and they all say that this is you know
incredibly risky and that's actually
what stops
a lot of oil traders doing trading like
this they simply aren't willing to
stomach
the risk but cuddles and his friends
were
so when the kind of final calculations
came down the
group of the nine most profitable
traders made
660 million dollars or thereabouts
between them i mean if you can imagine
i think three or four of them made in
excess of 100 million each
one of the astonishing things about this
trade is that two of the individuals who
made more than a hundred million dollars
in a single day
were in their twenties one of them was
22 years old
you know only a few years earlier he'd
been posting on his social media
about doing teenage stuff with his mates
in town and going to
see girls and rap music and here he is a
few years later making 100
million dollars in a single day's
trading when me and liam discovered that
we were just
we couldn't believe it we couldn't
believe what we were seeing
all trading is a zero-sum game anytime
you're making money as an all-trader
someone else is losing it amongst the
biggest losers were the investors in
this chinese
fund crude oil treasure fund
there were thousands of them and they
lost everything lots of people had put
their savings into oil funds
they lost money that day big banks and
brokers who sort of stand in the middle
of trading parties they lost money that
day
and another interesting thing is the oil
producing countries like
kuwait or canada they sell oil
as an average of the wti closing price
over the preceding month
so the fact that one of those numbers in
that average was -37
meant if you can imagine countries like
saudi arabia and
q8 potentially lost a couple of dollars
on every single barrel of oil they sold
that month
vega capitals traders made such an
extraordinary sum of money
that it was inevitable there would be
some scrutiny of what they did
but it wasn't just the sums of money
they made in the vital half an hour
before the settlement price was set
they were by far the biggest sellers of
oil futures in the market
which is an incredible thing to think
about when you consider that the other
participants in that oil market are
going to be
the world's biggest banks you know oil
majors bp and shell
and here you have a group of nine guys
in essex who are having this significant
influence over a global market for oil
i mean i think you have to assume that
if these guys have made
seven million or ten million dollars
they probably would be celebrating in
essex right now but the fact that they
made closer to 700 million
has meant that they are facing
understandable scrutiny
we wrote individually to all the all the
vega traders who
did exceptionally well that day and we
got a letter in response from a law firm
representing the group and the law firm
was at pains to point out
number one they haven't been accused of
any wrongdoing
um that they all traded independently
and separately
and they basically all made up their own
minds that this was what was going to
happen in oil markets based on publicly
available knowledge
and decided to execute this trade
what i love about these stories is
there's a real variance
of opinion and some people will look at
what happened and think that must be
dodgy they all traded at the end of the
day they all made a huge amount of money
while all these people lost
that's shocking but lots of people say
these guys are acute disadvantage
they're in a market that's inhabited by
you know huge technology driven
funds and firms and oil giants that have
got all the advantages in the world
and when you get a bunch of essex
geezers who essentially
beat the market and find a way to make a
huge amount of money
they should get a pat on the back really
because that's the dream
[Music]
since this happened a lot of the guys
have stopped trading the monthly
settlements that they've done so well
out in the past
several of them have set up new
companies they've essentially gone very
quiet you know any kind of social media
presence they had is
has kind of closed down by all accounts
they're
you know waiting this out it's certainly
too early to try and predict
how the regulatory investigations are
going to pan out
you know we just don't know there's a
number of potential outcomes for these
guys
you know potential punishments if there
are any findings of manipulation against
vega
or anyone affiliated with it might be
you could be fined
uh you could be banned from trading and
you know in the most extreme cases there
have even been criminal prosecutions in
the past
of uh of people who have been found to
have been manipulating the settlements
and uh misconduct related to trade at
settlement
there are other outcomes too you know
one one obvious one is going to be
they're able to walk away from this
life-changing trade
with all the money that they made and
celebrated as heroes in the trading
community that you know they'll go down
as legends